now that they've gotten a good chance to
see him what do fans think of the new
joker are they comparing him to heath
ledger's iconic performance positively
or negatively keep watching to find out
the full scope of opinion minor spoilers
for the batman are ahead barry kyogen
only appears as a joker in a single
scene of the batman where he bonds with
the riddler in arkham state hospital the
brief glimpse audiences got of him left
them hungry for more and that appetite
was sated with the release of a deleted
scene in which batman visits joker to
ask for help tracking down the riddler
the five-minute scene gives us our best
look yet at kyogen's clown prince of
crime and it's a sight to behold joker's
face is blurred through the glass
barrier between him and the dark knight
but we get some close-ups on his
nightmarish grin and sunken eyes
meanwhile the back of his head is a
gruesome patchwork of green hair and
what appears to be burn wounds when
batman shows joker a file on the riddler
joker taunts him telling him that the
riddler's tactics are similar to his own
he suggests that batman is having a hard
time catching the killer because deep
down you're not sure
you think they deserved it
many fans wish the scene had been
included in the theatrical cut of the
film kyogen definitely gets to show off
his range especially when compared to
his recent turn as a conflicted hero
druid in marvel's eternals across social
media fans of the batman went wild over
the scene mere moments after it was
released and struck up vigorous
discussion of kyogen's new take on the
joker when batman visits joker there's
an immediate implication that the two
have already tangled pattinson's batman
has only been on his crime-fighting
mission for just shy of two years but
has already put his arch-nemesis behind
bars joker remarks
so it seems a first cross path about a
year ago he also seems to be intricately
familiar with how batman thinks many
fans love the dynamic one youtube
commenter wrote this clarice hannibal
dynamic between batman and joker has so
much potential i hope they do more of
this another user echoed the sentiment
writing i love the fact that they have
an already established history and
dynamic with one another on the dc
cinematic subreddit users seem to agree
wanna find loving pattinson's batman
emotionally a brick wall still learning
but overconfident while still growing
into the batman persona batman doesn't
appreciate the danger of going to joker
feeding into his mania and perception of
their relationship really fascinating
acting work by both kyogen's joker is by
far the most grotesque we've seen on the
big screen a stark contrast to the more
realistic version where queen phoenix
played in joker and even outdoing heath
ledger's scarred appearance in the dark
knight beneath layers of prosthetics and
makeup the eternal star is barely
recognizable patchy hair gives way to
hideous blistered wounds across his head
and hands and his mangled grin is a
lopsided more of mismatched teeth it's a
bold look and fans seem to be split on
it on the dc cinematic and batman
subreddits some fans were unsure what to
think of kyogen's wounded appearance
with one commenting this figured face is
fine i think and i know he's supposed to
have a congenital disorder so disgusting
mouth i get it but i definitely don't
like that he's almost bold another
chimed in the makeup on barry's joker is
actually pretty cool gives heavy heath
ledger vibes not a fan of the lost hair
though other fans immediately loved what
they were seeing one enthused this is
what i've always wanted the joker to
look like in live action creepy and
monstrous as hell and a few hated it of
course one fan wrote that the design was
terrible adding they do know it wasn't
the makeup that made ledger a great
joker it's like someone said oh the
scars were cool what if we gave him
scars on his scars even with the
criticism something about this new joker
is resonating with fans it's saying
something that fans find kyogen's
performance as worthy of comparison to
leger's iconic joker in christopher
nolan's the dark knight when kyogin
posted a still from the scene on his
twitter account a fan replied it's
sacrilegious but you might have just
aced heath ledger in a four minute clip
bloody brilliant if you're good at
something never do it for free
not everyone was as pleased with the
resemblance though another fan rose can
we stop making every new cinematic
iteration of the joker a repeat of heath
ledger like yeah heath nailed the role
but that doesn't mean you should
repeatedly try to replicate the style
and energy he brought to the character
another fan countered that kyogen isn't
doing a repeat of leger's performance
there are just common elements to the
joker as a character i don't get why
people say barry kyogen is doing a heath
ledger impression in the batman that's
just a joker
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one